Speaker 1: Well, we're starting with two stories
from Texas today, and nothing really says the
Christmas spirit, like Texas sending busses
of migrants to deathly cold temperatures at
Kamala Harris's house. And that's exactly what
took place. And yet Texas has real problems to
deal with, specifically the fact that they have
another power emergency. This is not a show from
last year. Texas having another power emergency
for more or less the exact same reasons that they
have in the past. We're going to get to that,
though. Let's start with the migrant story. New
York Times reporting busses of migrants arrive
at Kamala Harris's home on Christmas Eve. About
130 migrants from Texas were bused to the vice
president's home on one of the coldest Christmas
Eves on record in the nation's capital. This
is a good article by Stephanie Ly that explains
what took place. Over 100 migrants arrived near
Kamala Harris's home Saturday evening, one of
the chilliest Christmas Eves on record. Volunteers
anticipated three busses with about 130 migrants
to arrive in New York on Christmas Day. The busses
were rerouted to the Washington area because of
road closures and frigid conditions. Migrants
arrived in Washington after a 36 hour journey,
some with little more than a T-shirt or
a light blanket. The mutual aid group
helped coordinate travel and housing
for them, provided food, coats, shoes,
other warm articles. Temperatures plunged below
20 degrees. The mutual aid groups said the busses
were set by the Texas Division of Emergency
Management following the directive of Governor
Greg Abbott's office. I don't have to tell you
whether he's a Democrat or Republican. You know,
from what he did, quote, they've been doing
this for a few months now. It's all for the
spectacle. The cruelty is the point. It's awful to
use people in this manner for political reasons.
We have video and as you will see here, folks
arriving as you see some some are wearing shorts,
quite literally shorts. The temperatures got below
20 degrees, busses being unloaded. And this is a
political stunt. It is farcical. It is disgusting.
It's also dangerous. It puts people in danger
because of the temperatures. We have another video
here as well. You see the clock 10 p.m. there,
busses arriving. People have been handed blankets,
at least some of them have. But you do see folks
very much under dressed and it got very, very
cold in the northeast on Christmas Eve. The White
House is assailing Texas Governor Abbott per a
report from Reuters writing the White House on
Monday accused Texas Governor Greg Abbott of
endangering lives after busloads of migrants
from the southwest border in Texas were dropped
near Vice President Kamala Harris home in DC. The
Republican. Abbott has not acknowledged the drop
and his office has not claimed responsibility.
Yeah. So what do we say? These are people who are
prioritizing their own agendas over the well-being
and safety of others. And it's nothing short of
disgusting and absurd. People's lives are being
put at risk. People woefully unprepared for the
temperatures that slammed the Northeast over the
holiday weekend. And they're being used as
political pawns. So, number one, we should
recognize that these are human beings. They are
looking for safety. They're looking for a better
life for themselves and their families. They don't
come to the United States willy nilly. Remember,
many of them are leaving families and the only
homes that they have known to take a risk and to
try to make a living. Now, remember, they are both
lazy and taking our jobs away. So they're lazily
taking all of our jobs by working. All of those
stories are completely pathetic and inconsistent.
We know that. But these are people who are making
life altering decisions to try to better their
circumstances. And there are folks like Texas
Republicans more than it's not even willing eager
to exploit them. Secondly, when governors do
this, Abbott, DeSantis, etc., not only does
it fly in the face of basic human compassion
and decency, it often actually is misstating
or misunderstanding the legal status of many of
these folks. I don't yet know the legal status of
these hundred and 30 individuals. Oftentimes the
term migrant is used and then it's often replaced
with illegal immigrant. But in a prior busing
stunt where migrants were bused to the north,
they were folks who were actually they they
requested asylum and their cases were being
processed and they were not actually here. What
we would define as illegally per the law, per
asylum law. And so understand that very often it's
not even accurately making the very deranged and
inhuman point that they are trying to make. Last
thing, Americans are actually in agreement on many
aspects of the immigration debate, particularly.
If you were six when you were brought here by
your undocumented immigrant parents and from
age 6 to 20, you grew up in the United States,
went to school in the United States, etc. It
would be insanely cruel and illogical to send
that individual who was six when they came
here and is now 20 back to their country,
which isn't even really their country anymore.
And in fact, I came to the U.S. legally when I
was five and legally or illegally. My upbringing,
my schooling, my acculturation was in the United
States. Had I been brought here by my parents
illegally at age five to say when I was 20 in
the middle of college, you've got to go back
to Argentina would be extraordinarily inhumane.
And that is something that most Americans agree
with. And yet we are unable to make progress on
that. We've talked about why there are political
factions at play and on and on and on. Lastly,
really lastly, these bussing stunts will probably
have unintended consequences. And what I mean by
that is you send migrants to states and sometimes
they're not even told until they arrive that this
is happening. So it puts an additional strain
on local resources and it arguably exacerbates
difficult situations that the migrants find
themselves in. Okay. So you're irresponsibly
in short sighted, Lee, to get headlines doing
something which will actually make the problem
worse that you're trying to solve. Because if the
migrants were able to stay or go to a place that
was actually prepared and resource to receive
them, it would have a dramatically lower impact
on those communities. Nobody's saying there is
no impact when people arrive in a community,
but by deliberately choosing to willy
nilly at 10 p.m., bused folks to a place
that isn't even expecting them, you're
actually just making the problem worse.
So this is what Texas spent Christmas doing.
And meanwhile, look at what else is going on